- K thanks, bye.
(upbeat music)
- It's kinda sad but my
relationship with my phone
is my longest, most intimate relationship.
- Everybody who knows me
they know what's going on
in my life all the time
because I'm always on Snapchat
Stories or Instagram Stories.
- Pretty much anything I do
on my phone is a waste of time
unless I am doing something for work.
I have little to no idea
what I will be doing
except for the fact that
it involves my phone
and kind of going off
the grid a little bit?
- Okay...
Am I gonna get it back? (laughs)
Oh my God!
No!
- No.
- Oh no, this is the
phone my grandmother has.
- I do like the look.
But like functionally what am
I supposed to do with this?
- Okay, am I supposed
to use this for a week?
Oh no! (laughs)
- Oh, it has a camera!
- This is where I say, "I
love you guys, wish me luck,
and hopefully I survive."
You can have it, I can't
look at it anymore.
- One last selfie before I go.
- It's the first official day.
I'm taking this challenge very seriously.
- Someone over here
doesn't know how to turn on
her own phone
- I don't know
- [Rafa] How to turn my phone on (laughs)
- Look at the era we live in,
these privileged Millennials these days.
- You know the home screen
that we have on our iPhones?
This doesn't have that so
I don't know what to press.
- I am currently in the bathroom.
I have to go old school.
- I have to go to Staples but
I don't know where Staples is
so I had to print out
Google Maps. (laughs)
- Okay, first comes first,
learning how to fold a freaking map.
Help me!
So I added my parents as
contacts for the first time today
and it was struggle texting them.
Instead of hitting the space
bar which I was trying to find,
I hit send.
It literally says this
- I would go back to flip
phones, to be honest.
I feel like life was just a simpler time
We appreciated more
when we had flip phones.
- [Liz] Yeah, that's pretty good.
Okay!
- I'd put that on my Tinder profile.
- I actually had to ask my coworkers
what they did over this
past weekend and likewise,
they had no visibility into
what my weekend looked like,
so now I'm super mysterious.
- So the alarm on this stupid
flip phone did not go off.
It's now 9:30 and I'm supposed
to be at work at 9:30 so...
(subway chatter)
- I haven't charged all week, by the way,
and it's still alive somehow?
Now I realize how much battery
smartphones actually drain.
As long as I have something
to tell me the time
and something to tell me when
the train comes, I am good.
- Oh...
I am looking at PornHub.com
on a flip phone right now.
And it's a horrible user experience.
Yeah, I'm gonna have
to go offline for this.
- I'm becoming very
irritable very quickly.
It is really hindering my work
because I can't get my
emails, get my Slack messages.
- I miss emojis.
This is my life now.
- So we're just gonna wander
around the streets of New York
while it's raining.
Can I just look at your GPS?
Am I allowed to do that?
- Over the past few days I've
been a lot more productive
than I've been in a very long time
because I'm not texting here
and checking in with apps there.
- Today is Fri-yay,
or the last day that I'm
doing this stupid challenge.
Menu?
- I am vlogging from Hawaii today.
After a week of no iPhone
I feel like I'm getting
back from a little mini vaca
so I thought this was appropriate.
- Learned a trick with my phone, watch!
- At this point I've
gotten pretty frickin' good
at living life without an iPhone.
I've even figured out some hacks
with my flip phone.
- I'm going to treat
myself to a nice dinner,
and I think I might go
tech free for dinner.
Might just leave everything
including the stupid flip phone.
- You would think it's really dramatic
but it's classical addiction,
where you think you can't
live without something
and then you're like "I'm
fine, the world is fine,
they don't need my InstaStories
and I don't need theirs."
- The main thing that I noticed was
I was just keeping my head up
more and I was looking around
and noticing things I
hadn't noticed before.
I read parts of a couple different books.
- But it was just mainly
giving up social media
that was kind of a struggle,
especially because I did go out a lot.
Oh my God, that's actually really cool.
- Right?
- [Rafa] Thank you Jade, I love you!
Also I had to carry around a
map of Manhattan in my purse.
- If anything this has made
me more reliant on my iPhone
because I felt like a
part of me was missing.
I wasn't so easily accessible
and people couldn't reach me.
- I was just a lot more present
in everything that I did.
And I've never been so focused.
- Sometimes you've just
gotta live in the moment.
It's better you liking your own life
than posting on social media
and having other people envy yours.
- I just feel like I'm in a
better mental, spiritual place.
- My last words to this flip phone are
(phone click)
- I'm ready to be reunited with my iPhone.
- My baby!
- Feels good to have
this back in my hands.
It feels good and I feel
like a complete person again.
I'm gonna go take a bunch of selfies.
(techno music)